how can you possibly be this talented
does your handsomeness get in the way of
you like your everyday life
i can't think of any other questions
people would want to ask me i don't know
[Music]
i really hope this is being recorded
because if it isn't i've just gone
insane
[Music]
hi i'm hank azaria and apparently i'm
doing the wired auto complete interview
so here we go first thing how
to pronounce hank's area it's hank's
area it's self-explanatory
although some people in my family say
azaria i discovered
the azaria people insist they're right
but they are wrong
and i you know i have the mic here so i
win how
how tall is hank this area i am six feet
tall
exactly although with age it's
like i'm like five eleven and three
quarters now
how old is hank's area very getting very
personal the card is like actually
upsetting me i'm i'll be 57 uh in
uh in april as of april 25th 2021. i can
barely wait to see how insulting this
next one's going to be
ah no not how many characters does
hank's area voice
well on the simpsons alone i mean over a
hundred over the years but like 30 or so
running characters that appear
consistently and then you know too many
to count in other
venues the arlington does hank is area
we're really uh
this is like a journey into grammar here
does hank is there a drink
well i you know i drink like water and
stuff to live and survive sure i do not
drink alcoholic beverages
i've retired from that about uh oh 14
years ago
this next summer i was forced into
retirement um the thanks area sing
yes i mean i have to sing on the
simpsons all the time i sang on broadway
i would like to point out
that i believe in the history of
broadway musicals i'm the person
nominated for a tony with the least
musical talent ever in the history
of broadway so they pay me to sing every
once in a while
which they really shouldn't i would be
very disappointed if i showed up at
broadway theater and i was the one
singing
but you know what do i know what do they
know
does hank's area speak spanish no my
parent i grew up in a spanish-speaking
household
i understood spanish until i was a
teenager
and then i i lost a lot of it but uh my
both my parents are fluent in spanish
okay does hank thought
this this question killed me not
literally does hager have parkinson's
disease what a disturbing question no
no i also don't have to fill the record
no berry berry no scurvy
no legionnaires disease i don't know i'm
hoping that this is because in in the
last season of my show brockmire my
character had parkinson's and i i'd like
to think i did a convincing
handshake but i don't know don't have
parkinson's but thanks for asking
now what hank is area can i just answer
what haggis area what the hanka's area
is going on here i think that should be
a new
way of expressing ourselves what has
anxiety have been in that's a long
that's a that's a long uh i've been at
this for 35 years so
you got to google that one for the
birdcage the simpsons
i was recently on ray donovan i just
finished my show
brockmire was on friends uh
i was in spamalot on broadway i've done
a lot of stuff
kids what i think is area doing now i
just finished my show brockmire and now
i have a podcast
the jim brockmeyer podcast where i
interview the great and near great in
the world of sports and entertainment
got charles barkley and ben stiller and
don cheadle and joe
buck and colin coward and dan patrick
joining us
i'm also producer got many things in
development mom if you're watching this
i've been i've been busy stuff get off
my keys what is my ethnicity very nice
question
i'm an american jewish fellow my family
is are sephardic jews
meaning they were originally from spain
i mean like back in the 15th century
and that's why my family's
spanish-speaking because that the uh
all sephardic jews speaks a dialect of
spanish called latino which is a
fascinating dialect it's spanish
phonetic spanish written in hebrew
characters hebrew letters how about that
and my family went to greece for a long
time i am jewish by way of spain by way
of greece
when the hank is there this is like a
strange uh newspaper articles you need
the who what where when why how right
this is like doing this to myself
so i can't wait to see what the when was
hank azarian nominated for an oscar
i remember this very well that was the
12th of never it has never happened
i should have been nominated like 56
times
but boy that that's flattering that that
was if that's googled a lot
people also have assumed that i've
hosted snl but i never did so if lauren
if you're watching this give me a break
please throw me threw me a freaking boom
uh when did hank azaria join the
simpsons uh
the first year that it was a half hour
show which was back in 1988
boy i was 24 but i auditioned for it
originally i think i was 22.
the very first one was mo that's what i
auditioned
with and then follow her quickly by
chief chief with him
this is my first two characters
oh the way i stopped voicing appu i
really haven't uttered a sound as apoo
in about five or six years i only
announced that i was not doing that a
couple years ago
although oppo has appeared visually on
the show he hasn't uttered a word in
five or six years but there's a whole
nother long story that i'm sure you can
google
if you like now kids we move on to where
hank's area much like where's waldo
where is hank's area in frame
right here congratulations you've won
where
is hank's are you from i am from new
york specifically queens specifically
forest hills new york a lot of great uh
people from forest hills you got paul
simon
david caruso ray romano from my hometown
we actually ray romano's mom was my
music teacher
in forest hills how about that all right
we got where does hank's area live no my
actual dress i'm not giving it to you
but i moved back to uh new york
about six years ago it's our final board
kids it's kind of said who
hank is area who has hank is there a
dated my goodness we're getting personal
a lot of people a lot of people in show
business i don't know i don't think i
should out them there was a while there
i have to be honest where
if i turned on the tv i saw a lot of
people i dated
at one time or another i don't know
whether i'm proud or ashamed of that
somewhere in between
and i've dated many uh civilians as well
i once dated a um
a medical examiner one state a woman who
did autopsies
how about that one uh
who do you think they're playing friends
i played david the scientist guy
who was in love with phoebe i got beaten
out uh by the very handsome uh paul rudd
which i actually was sad about i really
wanted to end up with phoebe i found out
like everybody else and i read the
script i'm like ah
i don't end up with phoebe but you know
i think she made the right choice he
went on to be ant-man and i went on to
be gargamel
so you know i played david the scientist
guy on friends but i auditioned to be
joey
and uh spoiler alert i didn't get it i
thought the show was so good i was right
about that
that i asked to come back and i said i
gotta go back and try it again
and they let me very kindly and then
they very quickly threw me out again but
then they were
nice enough to offer me david the
scientist guy
who's necessarily his wife my lovely
wife katie
uh katie wright katie is area now we
have uh
we have an almost 12 year old son hal i
like to call her a recovering actress
a former actress katie was a really uh
really good actress she did she worked a
lot she played susan day in the
partridge family movie
and she was on a spin-off of beverly
hills 90210 or melrose place i think it
was called malibu shores
my favorite of hers though is she did a
mentos commercial that you can still
catch on youtube all right i think i
think i've uh
i think i did it i guess i would ask
those questions if i were googling
myself i'm still disturbed by the
parkinson's question
no as far as i know i'm disease-free so
thanks for asking